comment ça tu t'es perdu stéphane mais
enfin je sais pas qu'est ce qu'il ya
autour de toi mais bon je crois qu'on va
l'envoyer faire un petit stage chez les
fourmis du désert des chercheurs de
toulouse étudie les fourmis du désert
depuis plusieurs années maintenant et
particulièrement les aspects ce cas
taghli fils fortis et mélo for us bas
beauty qui sont très doués pour
s'orienter puisque stéphane en tout cas
ces fourmis aux grandes jambes se
déplacent extrêmement vite près d'un
mètre par seconde ce qui ne facilite pas
leur étude
d'autant plus qu'elles vivent dans le
désert et comme elles ne sont pas du
tout agressive elle préfère sortir
chercher de quoi se nourrir quand la
température du sol dépasse les 50 degrés
et sans rupture de trouver personne à
part des chercheurs particulièrement
déterminés et résistant à la chaleur au
beau milieu du sahara ou de la steppe
australienne ces fourmis parts
individuellement à la recherche de
nourriture et elle retrouve le chemin de
leur fourmilière sans marquer leur
passage avec des phéromones
contrairement à beaucoup d'autres
espèces que l'on retrouve dans nos
jardins
les chercheurs ont alors montré qu elle
se servait principalement de la mémoire
visuelle de leur environnement ce que
devraient apprendre stéphane lors de ses
déplacements la fourmi regarde
régulièrement autour d'elle elle scanne
son environnement en particulier
lorsqu'elles ne le connais pas et au
ralenti ça donne ça
[Musique]
dans une première expérience les
chercheurs ont disposé de grands repères
visuels sur le chemin entre la
fourmilière et une source de nourriture
à partir de ce que l'on connaît du champ
de vision des fourmis les chercheurs ont
même reconstitué ce que la fourmi
pourrait voir dans ces conditions ça
vous paraît pas fou comme but 0 1
et pourtant c'est comme ça que les
fourmis retrouvent leur chemin et très
rapidement elles sont donc induite en
erreur si les chercheurs cash ou des
places une partie des repères visuels
mairie chercheurs sont allés plus loin
et ils ont montré que les fourmis
pouvait apprendre de leurs mauvaises
expériences et adapter leur trajet pour
éviter les obstacles qu'elles ont déjà
rencontré pour cela les scientifiques
ont créé dans un coin de step
australienne
un véritable parcours pour fourmies
[Musique]
à partir de leur nid ici entouré d'un
sceau rouge les fourmis ne peuvent aller
que sur un grand pont aux parois
glissante
ici en blanc qui les amène droit au sol
blanc dans lequel se trouve la
nourriture et pas n'importe quelle
nourriture des morceaux de cookies
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
reprenons le chemin des fourmis au bout
du pont elle se retrouve 10 cm au dessus
du sol cookies et peuvent donc se
laisser tomber ou soca parcours mais les
fourmis n'ont qu'un sens de circulation
possible et peuvent s'entraîner à faire
des allers retours sans intervention
humaine mis sur leur trajet de retour
les chercheurs ont mis un puis enterré
aux parois lisses un véritable piège
qu'elle ne découvre qu'au dernier moment
et duquel elles ne peuvent ressortir que
par une planche incliné qu'elles
trouveront plus loin après avoir
traversé une forêt brindis qui les
empêche de courir en tombant dans le
puits le trajet des fourmis et donc
considérablement ralenti et cet
événement est mémorisé comme une
expérience très négative
les chercheurs observent alors que dès
le 2ème trajet la plupart des fourmis
s'arrête à la proche du puits pour
scruter l'environnement avant devient
bord pour le contourner ou d'y tomber
mais plus près de la planche qui permet
d'en ressortir et plus elles font trajet
plus le retour à la fourmilière et
efficace
l'expérience montre que les fourmis se
souviennent et reconnaissent
visuellement l'environnement dans lequel
elles se trouvaient juste avant la chute
et ses souvenirs visuels sont associés
dans leur mémoire à une expérience
négative qu'elle cherche ensuite à
éviter cette étude établit donc eu la
mémoire des fourmis et capables
d'intégrer des images de façon
chronologique au moins sur quelques
secondes et d'y associer après coup un
caractère repoussant un mécanisme qui se
révèle particulièrement efficace pour
optimiser les trajets et la similarité
des cerveaux à travers toutes les
espèces d'insectes mais se penser aux
chercheurs que ce talent pourrait être
partagée par d'autres comme les abeilles
ou les mouches
voilà la prochaine étape pour les
scientifiques qui fourmille d'idées
nouvelles et d'intégrer ces résultats à
leur modèle du système nerveux des
insectes pour dévoiler d'autres facultés
fourmis d'agde
et si tu as aimé ce four minable
parcours abonne toi